>> THIS PURGE IN HOMELAND
SECURITY.
>> ARE WE NOW BEGINNING TO SEE
HIM ACT OUT IN THE FORM OF
PURGING AND NOT LISTENING TO ANY
LOGIC?
>> Laura: IS A PURGE, THEY
SAY.
SO WHEN PEOPLE AREN'T GETTING
THE JOB DONE, YOU LEAVE THEM IN
FOR AS LONG AS POSSIBLE.
ONLY IN WASHINGTON WITH THAT BE
A MONTAGE WE COULD PUT TOGETHER.
CAN YOU IMAGINE DOING THAT IN
THE BUSINESS WORLD?
DONALD TRUMP HAS MADE A NUMBER
OF MOVES AS IT RELATES TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF: SECURITY AND NOT
A MOMENT TOO SOON.
CHRISTER NIELSEN IS AS THE
DEPARTMENT OF DHS HEAD
SECRET SERVICE DIRECTOR RANDOLPH
"TEX" ALLES IS BEING REMOVED
AFTER STORIES ABOUT LAX SECURITY
ESPECIALLY AT MAR-A-LAGO.
AND THEN THE DIRECTOR OF YOU CIS
WAS ALSO ON HIS WAY OUT.
THAT HAS NOT BEEN CONFIRMED.
SOME IMMIGRATION HARDLINERS ARE
CALLING FOR HIM TO BE SPARED.
JOINING ME NORTH REACTION,
FORMER ACTING DIRECTOR OF
I.C.E., TOM HOMAN.
WHAT ABOUT THESE PERSONNEL
MOVES?
>> I THINK THE PRESIDENT -- WE
ALSO FOR THE PLEASURE OF THE
PRESIDENT.
I THINK IT'S FRUSTRATED AT WHAT
IS GOING ON RIGHT NOW, HE'S
LOOKING TO GO ON A DIFFERENT
DIRECTION.
AS HE SAID, A TOUGHER DIRECTION.
I HAVE NOT BEEN INVOLVED IN ANY
OF THESE DECISIONS.
I'M ON THE OUTSIDE.
BUT ALL THREE OF THEM I THINK
DESERVE SOME RESPECT.
THEY DID SERVE THEIR NATION,
DIFFICULT JOBS.
HALF OF CONGRESS DON'T LIKE
THEM, THEY DON'T SUPPORT WHAT
THEY ARE DOING.
>> Laura: YOU HAVE TOUGH SKIN,
THICK SKIN.
MOST PEOPLE WILT UNDER THE
PRESSURE.
DONALD TRUMP IS THE ONLY GUY WHO
COULD HAVE WITHSTOOD THIS, BUT
THINK ABOUT THIS, -- UNDERNEATH
YOU, THEY DO THE CREDIBLE FEAR
SCREENING CAN PEOPLE COME INTO
THE COUNTRY FROM
CENTRAL AMERICA, THEY STAY THE
CREDIBLE FEAR, THEY ARE RELEASED
INTO THE SYSTEM, SEVEN TO 14
DAYS, THEY GET OUT.
A LOT OF THEM YOU NEVER AC
AGAIN.
THERE'S A LOT OF THINGS THEY
COULD DO TO RE-EXAMINE THE WAY
THAT CREDIBLE FEAR SCAMMING IS
DONE, WHAT THEY THINK, VARIOUS
PARTS OF EL SALVADOR, HONDURAS,
WHETHER THEY ARE DANGEROUS OR
WHETHER THIS IS JUST A SCRIPT
BEING USED.
NONE OF THAT WAS DONE.
WITH ALL THESE HARDLINERS OUT
THERE GOING, THIS GUY, I DON'T
KNOW HIM, BUT HE'S THE GREATEST
THING SINCE SLICED BREAD.
THE HEART PROBLEM IS, THINGS
AREN'T GETTING DONE.
BEYOND CONGRESS, AND CONGRESS
HAS TO ACT, THERE ARE FEDERAL
THINGS THAT CAN BE DONE, AGENCY
LEVEL ACTIONS.
BUT YOU HAVE TO HAVE A STRONG
CONSTITUTION TO DO THAT.
EVEN IF YOU AGREE WITH THE
PRESIDENT ON THE UNDERLYING
ISSUES.
>> THERE ARE SOME THINGS TO BE
DONE.
I TALKED ABOUT THIS BEFORE,
I.C.E. CAN DO MORE THINGS --   -
WHEN I WAS IN, I WAS IN MANY
MEETINGS WITH ALL THESE FOLKS
AND I ACTUALLY THOUGHT FRANCIS
WAS DOING A GOOD JOB AT WHAT HE
HAD OF THE TIME.
I THINK JUST LIKE THE SECRETARY
SAID, I THINK THE LAW STRANGE
THEM SOMETIME.
>> Laura: NOT ON EVERYTHING.
CREDIBLE FEAR, THEY CAN DO A LOT
WITH.
>> I'M NOT A CREDIBLE FEAR
EXPERT.
>> Laura: THE NEW HEAD OF DHS
DESERVES HIS TEAM, ACTING HAD.
HE DESERVES HIS OWN TEAM BENEATH
THEM.
THIS IS A CRISIS.
I LIKE THE FACT THAT THE
PRESIDENT MAKES A CHANGE.
IT'S NOT WORKING, CLEARLY.
WE HAVE A TEAM IN PLACE THAT
ASKED EXECUTE AND GET THE JOB
DONE.
>> I THINK KEVIN MCALEENAN IS A
GOOD CHOICE.
I WORKED WITH HIM SO SHOULDER TO
SHOULDER THE LAST FEW YEARS.
WE WORK TOGETHER UNDER JEH
JOHNSON WHEN THE FIRST CRISIS
HAPPENED.
>> Laura: HERE WE ARE.
>> KEVIN CAN HIT THE GROUND
RUNNING, GREAT RELATIONSHIP.
HE IS A GREAT RELATIONSHIP WITH
THE GOVERNMENT OF MEXICO, SO I
THINK HE CAN GET SOME THINGS
DONE.
>> Laura: BY THE WAY, ANOTHER
FEDERAL JUDGE, NINTH CIRCUIT
DISTRICT COURT JUDGE RULED
AGAINST THE ADMINISTRATION
TODAY, NONE ANOTHER INJUNCTION
GOES TO EFFECT ON FRIDAY.
THE ADMINISTRATION CAN'T DEPORT
PEOPLE TO MEXICO OR SEND PEOPLE
TO MEXICO PENDING THEIR ASYLUM
APPLICATIONS, WHICH, UNDER
FEDERAL LAW, IS ALLOWED.
WE NOW HAVE JUDGES THAT ARE A
PERMANENT PART OF THE ANTI-TRUMP
THE MIC RESISTANCE.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP -- IT'S
POLITICIZED BY THE OTHER THING
IS, ARE WE SURPRISED?
THESE PEOPLE, THEY ARE ESCAPING
FEAR OF PERSECUTION FROM -- THEY
CAN ESCAPE THAT FEAR IN MEXICO.
>> Laura: THAT IS WHY THEY
THINK THEY CAN GO TO MEXICO